while everyone was uh sucking each other
off and yeah in the desert i was in the
coolest place in america actually a
little town called brookfield wisconsin
that is
an hour outside of milwaukee that's why
you are the best yeah catfishing people
by way of comedy venues you know i'm
like hey i'm coming to chicago and then
i find out on the day oh actually i'm in
a strip mall 45 minutes outside of
chicago
yeah and everyone's pissed they're not
pissed but they're like i drove for this
in the midwest i'm like you drive for
everything so yeah we do too though we
do yeah but in the midwest it's like
five hours you know i drove three hours
for this it's like there wasn't [ __ ]
else i drove three hours this morning
that is true yeah
yeah and i'm driving right back after
how much does that suck i know we got
things i do for this [ __ ] podcast
that's why i'm the best influencer it is
true yeah you do sacrifice a lot you
sacrifice a lot to come talk for two
hours exactly exactly it's unreal
the struggle people don't see that you
go through man
[Music]
that's true i'm glad that you said that
dude it makes me feel good cody made the
sweet semen joke for you guys so he
could be slightly humiliated in front of
jack harlow so he could talk about it on
his podcast which you all did not notice
preach or think about while he was
watching coachella reach
that stinky ass fart that i did that was
a gift i did that for you alexis you
should be thankful that cody would be so
kind as to bust ass yeah i trojan horsed
it into a party with [ __ ] leo famous
baseball player the weeknd famous
uh
indoor soccer player famous famous span
of days yeah famous man that happened
after the week yeah
the weekend everyone's favorite time i
had no place at that [ __ ] party no
business being there speaking of things
that um you shouldn't be a part of i'm
not gonna say the location but uh i went
to a place that you could comfortably
reason was a front thinking there was
late night food okay it came up on
google we go there and it just seems
like you know like uh like a latino bar
you know there's a couple slot machines
in there there's two pool tables a lot
of young dudes hanging out in there
specifically like young early 20s guys
and there was us it was me tom elena and
zayad my opener and uh we walk in and
we're like man this is an interesting
vibe wouldn't expect this out here in
[ __ ] wisconsin when we go up to the
uh
to the bar
lady's serving alcohol and tom walks up
and he's like uh yeah we're looking to
get some food and she kind of makes a
gesture and she goes one second then
this like 6-3 dude walks out comes up to
us and he's a little buzzed and he goes
um what are you looking for
we didn't pick up on that okay
we just what are you looking for i'm
like i was just looking for some food
and he goes what kind of food and tom
whatever you make here yeah yeah tom's
like ah just you know
and tom is answering like uh you know
like literally
he's not getting it he's like uh
i don't know
tacos burritos
uh whatever you got and the dude's like
oh yeah kitchen's closed and and then
we're like uh okay so something's not
right society and there's people inside
the thing yeah eating or what are they
doing
they're just talking
all right there's a couple of guys
drinking dudes talking and just a couple
couple of them drinking but not really
and this is the weirdest thing when we
pulled up there's a dude sitting on the
corner of the bar he turned his back to
us looked at us he smiled he got up and
he gave us his chair it was just like a
couple gestures that didn't seem right
so whatever so as i he
he kind of just like instinctively he's
like yeah you know we'll get four drinks
he like gets two shots he like slams
them real quick grabs modelo pounds it
we're like we're all kind of like we
should get the [ __ ] out of here so we
dip
and we go outside there's a dude he's
like taking a piss by the dumpster and
buddy had a stream on him that's not
really relevant to the story that kid
was pissing like a fire hose it was
crazy nice so there's like a cadillac
that's on and it's idled and i think
it's his because he was taking a piss
like some feet away from it and there's
just a there's a 36 pack of corona just
sitting by the back wheel of the car
then the guy who asked us what we were
looking for for food comes out of the
back of the place he like makes eye
contact and i think he like either like
he whistled or he did like some subtle
gesture and then he goes inside and then
some dude comes from the front of the
bar grabs the box and then walks the box
into a house like adjacent from the bar
it was just like you know and then like
we saw that whole interaction and then
tom was like oh they definitely wanted
us to buy drugs
and then we started processing like all
his words like what are you looking for
if you serve food and you walk in you're
like hey guys what's going on sorry
kitchen's closed it's just drinks right
now wouldn't you say that like if you're
a restaurant yeah but like then we
started realizing after he asked us what
we were looking for we told him like
food he stood there just watching us
like while zaya ordered the drinks and
we were talking amongst each other he
didn't walk away he was just beaming at
us
to make sure you aren't cops i don't
know what i'm not saying what but it's
really weird to ask four patrons what
are you looking for and then just stare
at them while they drink but i don't
understand if it was a drug front then
why would there be other people in there
drinking and staying like if you're
buying their if you're going there to
buy drugs you just buy the drugs and
leave i don't think those guys were
patrons dude they were the guys that
were selling i think they like they go
there because like we so then um zai's
family came in the next day we're kind
of like laughing we're like dude i don't
know like we went there we think it
might have been a front like we're not
sure and then we're going to eat oh
cause then that's what happened after
like a point in the conversation where
we kept saying like no we want food the
lady who's like serving uh drinks she
like tapped the big guy and she like
says something in spanish and they start
laughing and then the big guy in spanish
was like uh you want food you go here
and he like told us where to go and it i
it hit me after i'm like oh they
probably process to each other oh they
actually want food and like they're
laughing about it
so
we walk out and besides like just trying
to act normal so there's two guys out
there smoking and he looks at one of the
dudes he's like yo you got a cigarette i
could bum and the dude is smoking a
cigarette he's just like
says [ __ ] nothing just looks at him
it's just like and then like immediately
you caught that dude's vibe was like
just don't talk to him we drove by the
next day that same guy was on the porch
smoking cigarettes like his demeanor was
not like i come and drink here it's like
nah i hang here yeah and so
the whole thing just felt like you know
i can't say for sure what they're doing
but the phrase what are you looking for
is a very weird first question for a
place that is marked as serving food
yeah then we started looking at the
google reviews and we started laughing
because they were all like really vague
[Laughter]
they're like
great steak
and every every everyone is different
like different type of food great
quesadillas no dude i think there's one
that says great sandwiches fantastic
meatloaf cool lasagna had a great kobasa
sausage here like what the [ __ ] does
this place serve what genre is this i'm
gonna show you the name of this place
don't say this [ __ ] out loud
[Laughter]
if we can believe it just please bleep
that [ __ ] out so you couldn't have
ordered any of this [ __ ] no that's the
crazy part that's funny because like i
can't really say this without like
referencing what it's called but it's
pretty clear what type of food they
serve for you to go in and say like hey
i got some food he's like what do you
want it's like exactly the one kind the
thing that you're saying that you're
supposed to make absolutely delicious
food and wonderful service
best quality steak
yeah like all these reviews are so funny
it was it was like a movie like there
was a record scratch when we walked in
every dude at the bar was like
yeah that's me
you're probably wondering how i got how
i ended up here
yeah 10 minutes later my face is in a
brick just [ __ ] yeah
oh dude brookfield is an interesting
place
you